mientras está trabajando con una función
que contiene los siguientes puntos aquí
están los valores de x y aquí los
valores de iu y nos preguntan esta
función es lineal o no lineal podemos
reconocer una función lineal porque para
cada cambio de x vamos a obtener un
incremento igual en que cada vez que x
cambia en una unidad que cambien tres
unidades o en cinco unidades pero el
cambio es siempre el mismo si así sucede
en una función podemos saber que estamos
tratando con una función lineal por
ejemplo vemos que aquí los valores de x
cambian en una unidad cada vez y vamos a
ver si los cambios en yes son siempre
iguales si no son iguales entonces esta
función no es lineal y lo podemos
mostrar haciendo la gráfica ahora si los
cambios en x son de diferentes valores
por ejemplo si tenemos 1 luego 2 y luego
4 lo que tenemos que hacer entonces es
dividir el cambio en entre el cambio en
x y siempre nos debe dar una constante
déjenme escribir de este lado
si la función es lineal entonces el
cambio en el cambio en g
sobre el cambio en x
cambio en x será siempre constante
siempre constante
en este ejemplo el cambio en x es
siempre uno vamos de 1 a 2 de 2 a 3 de 3
a 4 y de 4 a 5 el cambio siempre es 1 y
para que esta función sea lineal el
cambio en jet debe ser constante vamos a
tomar el cambio y lo vamos a dividir
entre 1 ok vamos a ver si este cambio es
constante de 11 a 14 el cambio es 3
cuando vamos de 14 a 19 el cambio es 5 y
ya estamos viendo que no es constante en
este punto no cambio en 3 sino que
cambio en 5 en este otro punto el cambio
es 7 y por último aquí el cambio es de 9
el cambio se va incrementando no es un
cambio constante así que podemos saber
que esta función no es una función
lineal
y lo podemos comprobar con la gráfica
aquí voy a dibujar el eje vertical el
eje i
y debemos llegar a 35 5 10
20 25 30 y 35 y aquí voy a dibujar el
eje x obviamente la escala no va a ser
igual aquí tengo 1 2 3
4 y 5 y empiezo a poner los puntos el
primero es 111 donde x es uno y es 11 es
más o menos por aquí en el siguiente x
es 2 y 14 éste está por aquí cuando x es
36 19 x es 3 10 19 y lo ponemos por aquí
cuando x es 4 10 26 x es 4 10 26 más o
menos por aquí y por último x 5 y 6 35 x
5 y ya es 35 este nos queda por aquí y
vemos inmediatamente que el resultado no
es una línea recta una función lineal
produce una línea que se vería más o
menos así
por eso se llama función lineal pero
esto que grafica mos aquí no es una
función lineal los cambios en y se van
incrementando